letzte woche habe ich mal ein schlüssel
verloren uns damit meine freundin und
mich ausgesperrt ein paar minuten später
ist der schlüsseldienst aufgekreuzt hat
innerhalb von zehn sekunden
die tür aufgemacht und 180 euro dafür
ein gesagt in diesem moment ging mir
eins zu eins durch den kopf was das kann
auch räder und dafür den er knapp 20
euro
nicht mit mir während ich nämlich
schlösser knacken in diesem video werden
wir herausfinden wie schnell man dicke
vorhängeschlösser fahrradschlösser und
sogar haus türen öffnen kann
und das ganz ohne schlüssel sondern mit
niedrigen wie man es bei skyrim kennt
und ich finde heraus ob man schlösser
jetzt merke ich mit einer büroklammer
öffnen kann wie man es aus dem film
kennen dieses video wird unterstützt von
dash lane der schlüsseldienst hat eine
spezielle karte grundlinie durch gezogen
in der theorie funktioniert das so die
möglichst reißfeste und dünne karte wird
durch den türschlitz gezogen und
gerüttelt mit etwas fingerspitzengefühl
drückt sie dadurch die sogenannte tür
falle zu rücken und gibt die tür zum
öffnen frei ob das in der praxis jetzt
auch so leicht ist das fitness voraus
okay wenn ich einmal
darum
[Musik]
ganz anders aussah als ist dann doch
nicht
[Musik]
oh mein gott warum ich weiß nicht ob ich
mich freuen soll oder wenn ich dann zu
sagen sollte wenn du also wie zugegeben
viele andere die haustür hinter dir
nicht extra zu spät kann sie da ganz
einfach mit so einer karte oder sogar
einer zerschnittenen plastikflasche
öffnen wird das schloss allerdings
verriegelt ist man zumindest davor
sicher dann müsste das schloss nämlich
entweder mit gewalt zerstört oder mit
viel feingefühl und einem dietrich
geknackt werden uns das probiere ich
jetzt mit einem 19 euro dietrich set
komplett ohne irgendeine ahnung was ich
da eigentlich mache losgeht wir starten
wir mit diesem eher simpleren floss
nehme ich mal an sie ziemlich
faszinierend aus wie hier diese
einzelnen dinge wie sie auch immer
heißen nach unten gedrückt werden und
dann erst reden können ich hab noch gar
kein plan ich nehme einfach mal an dass
ich jetzt irgendwie versuchen muss diese
einzelnen finds nach unten zu drücken so
dass die alle richtig angeordnet sind
und man das offen kann sicher mehrere
davon verwenden
also die beiden zusammen ergeben so
ungefähr die gleiche form von
geschlossen haben damals gehabt weil ich
einfach irgendwie da so rein kommen
okay ich hatte wirklich eine komplett
falsche vorstellung wie das hier alles
eigentlich funktioniert also ich muss
nochmal so also hiermit halt druck
aufbauen in der stunde über halt dann
drehen wir sondern das erste was du
machen würde es wäre als du fühlst ok
viel bezahlt schon überhaupt 1
und jetzt wirst du schon dann besetzt
ist da drin so und das ist schon
gereicht bei dem ok noch mal langsam um
zu wissen wie das genau geht muss man
verstehen wie ein schloss funktioniert
das ziel ist es nämlich hier den frei
beweglichen zylinder kern zu drehen und
dadurch das schloss zu öffnen das wird
noch mal jedoch von diesen stiften
findet jeweils hat man oben einen aufbau
stift der von der fehler in den zylinder
kennen gedrückt wird und darunter den
sogenannten kern stift welcher separat
ist und sich im zylinder kern befindet
wird nun ein passender schlüssel
eingeführt schieben seine verschiedenen
hohen verzahnungen die kennt stifter und
dadurch auch die aufbaustufe genau in
die richtige position damit sich der
kern drehen kann und das schloss geht
auf in der aufbau stift muss also aus
dem zylinder kennen geschoben werden
ohne dass der kern stift zu weit nach
außen geschoben wird weil dieser dann
ebenfalls die drehung blockieren würde
um die drehung eines schlüssels zu
simulieren setzt man also einen hebel an
und drückt ihn in drehrichtung um die
verzahnung des busses zu simulieren kann
man mit verschiedenen niedrigen die
stifter nach unten drücken und dadurch
dass man mit dem hebel immer leicht in
richtung drückt klemmen die stifter dann
in der richtigen position fest nachdem
alle stifte nacheinander in die richtige
position gebracht wurden ist das schloss
geknackt also das können jetzt leicht
das ging er leicht ich jetzt einfach mal
beitragen probiert das denkmal lebens zu
können okay da hier bekommen die rein
das ganze leben wieder einmal hier sehr
umgedreht ohne zu sehen taste ich nur
mit meinem werkzeug die mechanik ab und
drückte alle pins an ihren platz
gras das ist recht heftig ich hab jetzt
mal zum baumarkt um mehr so ein
vorhängeschloss projekt hat nicht
theoretisch durch sehen kann ich bin ja
auch nicht ganz sicher ich glaube ich
mich ganz das einkaufen kann dass nichts
im leben da ist auch so leicht zu
knacken ist aber wird erzählt so wir
waren beim baumarkt von haben wie jedes
schloss gekauft zwei türschlösser hat
unterschiedlicher stärke einmal 36 und
dann hier noch mal ganz besonders
schlösser von den sicherheitsstufen zwei
bis sechs und wir schauen wir mal wie
weit ich komme weil das hier ist schon
richtig heftig wir fangen an mit der
nummer zwei diesem moment wenn das
schloss sicher verpackt ist als das
schloss selber ist dann können schon mal
schwieriger sein weil das schloss hier
ein bisschen kleiner ist jetzt kann ich
wirklich mit nur circa einer stunde
übung bereits ein handelsübliches
vorhängeschloss knacken mit werkzeug
dass jeder mal leben führen zwar nie
kaufen kann wenn ihr das auch mal
probieren wollte habe ich euch diese
sets in der video beschreibung verlinkt
gras das ging überraschend schnell also
wenn ihr sohn den kauf dann ist es ja
nicht mal vor so einem anfänger die mir
sicher das ist heftig stufe 2 habe ich
geschafft wir gehen weiter zu stufe 3
[Applaus]
die herangehensweise der kollege wird
darüber gedreht
geht ganz gut ich kann nicht genau sagen
wie pins das hier sind nicht ich kann
dir nicht zählen wirklich nicht aber
muss ich ja nicht vielleicht ein zugang
jetzt habe ich erst was drin daraus
sollen sagt meinecke wenn man den hebel
hierfür so gut
es ist ein profis zählen die einzelnen
pins beziehungsweise stifter und merken
sich welche sie auf welche art
bearbeiten müssen für das genau erzählen
fehlt mir aber noch das feingefühl
ich komme nicht voran problem hier das
andere werkzeug aufschlägt ist dass ich
bisschen stärker so hart aber nix
versuch nummer zwei ich nehme dafür mal
den ganz kleinen nebel
er ist drin das war schwierig haha stufe
3 habe ich auch gefragt was ist
schwieriger
sowas macht finde ich echt einen guten
eindruck also ich hätte mir vor dass ein
video das ding hier irgendwann gegangen
und hätte gedacht dass es sicher aber
ist es nicht diese selbst mit dem ich
angefangen habe das hab ich ja von
sebastian ausgeliehen
aber dieses hier das jetzt gerade eben
angekommen ist hat sich gestern nacht
auf amazon bestellt also schon ein
bisschen leid zugänglich die kunst des
schlösser knapp links fragt nicht wieso
sebastian manager schlösser knacken kann
also sicherheitsstufe 4 auf geht's ich
hatte ein gutes gefühl
ich krieg dich hin
okay noch mal einsam anderen der schon
einmal schwierig aber nicht nur die
schlösser werden von mal zu mal immer
besser sondern auch meine fähigkeiten
jetzt war er voll easy a ist ja mal
probieren jetzt ging es mega diese
nummer vier ist auch geknackt weitergeht
sind jetzt richtig gespannt mit
sicherheitsstufe
fünf dieser fette oshie der einige
pfingstritt glauben mindestens 56
[Musik]
ja oh mein gott ich habe es geschafft
ok auch diesen fetten aus sie auch wenn
es 20 minuten gedauert
das ist auf jeden fall räumlich doch
dieses schloss ist zu eng gebaut und
deswegen um längen schwieriger ich habe
kaum bewegungsfreiraum um meine dietrich
richtig zu positionieren und deswegen
okay aber vier der fünf handelsüblichen
schlösser konnte ich knacken und dabei
bin ich kein naturtalent ich gebe sowie
einen zehnminütigen crashkurs und
[Musik]
und nicht nur das übungslauf sondern
auch das stufe 2 schloss aus dem
baumarkt ist das heißt viel einen drauf
gekriegt nicht sicher vor ihr
apropos einbrechen jetzt wird es ernst
der versuch an unserer eigenen
wohnungstür also endlich ins reine
kommen mit einigen strafen
[Applaus]
diesmal komme ich nur mit dem schlüssel
wieder in die wohnung aber es ist noch
kein meister vom himmel gefallen
vielleicht sollte ich es zuerst mit
einem schwächeren türschloss für neun
euro aus dem baumarkt versuchen ich habe
sie in einem schraubstock damit das halt
genauso fest ist wie nach hause eben
auch und hier ist es war krass war wenn
ich das jetzt knapp dann könnte ich
nicht nur irgendein fahrrad klauen oder
war irgendwie eine abgesperrte baustelle
aufgehalten sondern sogar wirklich in
der wohnung einbrechen
der erste ging ziemlich easy habe ich
muss man so richtig eklig um die ecke
biegen
[Musik]
und dann nie mehr pins desto schwieriger
weil die weiter hinten sie sind desto
weniger bewegungsfreiraum hat man hier
ja ok mehr licht
[Musik]
ich kriege es nicht hin
ich war so nah dass man den haus
geschlossen wird nix aber zum glück oder
leider ist es nicht die einzige
möglichkeit wie man enden haus
einbrechen kann denn obwohl ein profi
bestimmt auch ein haus zu schloss mit
niedrigen knacken könnte 80 prozent
aller einbrüche geschehen nicht mit
dieser methode und auch nicht mit
unserem kartentrick sondern durch
aufhebeln oder aufbrechen aber so weit
werde jetzt nicht gehen um für dieses
experiments mehr tür zu öffnen
nichtsdestotrotz kann ich jetzt die
mehrheit diese vorhängeschlösser knacken
und das ist recht ein richtig cooles
gefühl ich sehe draußen die ganze zeit
diese schlösser an baustellen fahrrädern
und sonstwo und ich frage mich einfach
würde ich das jetzt klappen können aber
ich glaube das ist ziemlich illegal und
deswegen glaube ich über bei denen der
hängt ihr das funktioniert einfach mit
einer büroklammer die prümer den ersten
tenor unterzubringen
[Musik]
ich habe einfach diese schloss jetzt mit
seinem büro kam ein gift schon mal kann
man ein wochenschluss wirklich genau wie
schlüssel könnte natürlich auf eure
passwörter geknackt werden die beste
methode das zu verhindern ist es auf
jeder seite ein anderes passwort mit
möglichst vielen stellen klein und
großbuchstaben zahlen und sonderzeichen
zu verwenden merken kann sich das dann
leider keiner hier kommt deutschland
unser heutiges pons endspiel deutschland
ist eine app für handy und pc die nicht
nur europas würde sicher verwahrt
sondern diese auch automatisch bei
websites zum login einträgt geht zu
dreschen dot com / pommery und erhalte
der stein auf deinem ersten gerät
kostenlos und die ersten 100 von euch
erhalten 25 prozent rabatt auf den
premium service mit dem kot theorie
folgt mir gehen auf instagram wenn ihr
wissen wollt das experiment als nächstes
kommt und in mainz schon kleine
ausschnitte daraus sehen möchte schaut
gerne auch bei meinem zweiten kanal
vorbei wo ich aktuell jeden zweiten tag
ohne videos posten und wenn ihr mich auf
dieser reise begleiten unterstützt dann
abonniert gerne diesen kanal uns dann
sehen wir zunächst mal wieder macht's
gut
[Musik]